welcome to another sadler stories
this time i've got some props for you
and
these are some objects of clothing that
are particularly meaningful for me and i
think you'll see
why as i tell the story so
it it really has to begin with
christmas and this would have been 1999
as we were you know crossing into the
2000s and i was down in carbondale
studying philosophy as a graduate
student living in
a trailer park i was now at that point
i had gotten my you know masters i was
working on my
phd and they had trusted me with
my my own classes and i was now
you know teaching and and working on the
dissertation
and getting ready for prelims all these
different sorts of things that were
going on
and i was you know at that time living
in carbondale which is in southern
illinois
and my mother had moved recently from
one let's call it a suburb of milwaukee
menomonee falls to
to brookfield she'd bought a new house
there
sold the old house and it was uh you
know it was pretty new
i think we'd only been there once before
maybe like for thanksgiving
and you know so it was in a new
neighborhood
very different a very different kind of
place and she was she was hosting
holiday parties and very
proud of it and she um
you know i i took the the train up there
or the greyhound i don't even remember
which i took to get up there
you know and brought along uh my stuff
with me
and she asked me if there was there was
anything that i needed and i remember
this uh
this conversation that we had in class
um one of my professors who was also you
know a first generation college and
all that sort of stuff he he was giving
us advice and he said
you know you really need a black suit
black suits are really good you can use
them for everything except for a wedding
got a job interview wear your black suit
nobody's going to complain about that
got a funeral to go to you got a black
suit right there you know it's it's
good for just about every occasion if
you're only going to have one suit get
it get a black one
and i was like yeah you know as i
started telling her about this
this professor's idea and she said well
let's go out
shopping and you know my mother was
somebody who really
did enjoy shopping and i didn't always
like that myself
but you know i you know gotten let's say
accustomed to it
and she was like we're gonna go and get
you a black suit because you need a
black suit so
first we went to this this place
and i i don't even know if it's open
anymore it was in a strip
mall and she said i really like to go
here and get you know this is where i go
for my
my fancy clothes and she knew the guy it
was an older guy who is
you know sort of the suit seller i
suppose you call him or
there's probably a name for that he
probably did some of the tailoring as
well and took measurements
and she was like you know my my son
needs a a good suit
he's starting to teach and so you know
they're back talking back and forth
my mom was really a good talker i mean
if you think that i'm a talker
you should have heard her she really
lived for that sort of thing
and so he was a good salesperson and she
was in you know kind of a christmas
generous mood and she's like i'm gonna
get you these things as your
as your presence you really need to have
good
clothes for the the job that you're
moving into
you know it's fine that you've been kind
of dressing down for the last couple
years but now you need to to um you know
get your act in gear
and i do actually still have um two of
the things that she got me at that first
store we didn't get a black suit
instead the guy was like well you know
you can't go wrong with
a navy suit either and so all i have
left of that
is the jacket because i long sense
outgrew the
the pants but the jacket is actually
still pretty decent and i wear it every
once in a while you'll see this in some
of my videos
this is you know 20 years old at this
point
and still doing quite well for me i
can't match pants exactly to the color
because apparently they change the dyes
every year but i really do and i do
really do like this jacket it's it's
something that i
keep not only because it's you know
attractive and fits well
and wears well but also because it's a
way of remembering the generosity
of my mom and that that particular
evening and i should tell you a little
bit about that before i go on so
you know i was home for christmas there
was snow on the ground it was a snowy
evening
everything was kind of quiet and you
know we got in the car we drove
uh after we i think we had dinner or
something we drove out to these places
and she's like they'll still be open
don't worry about it
and you know i i tried the suit on and
it fit and she's like well this this is
pretty good
this will this will be useful for you as
you're teaching and i don't know how
many
classes i've taught or job interviews
i've gone to or things like that wearing
this suit and then she she saw something
else and she's like oh wow
you've got to have that let's see if
it'll actually
fit you try it on and it was a little
bit you know
i'm more into like neutral colors and
stuff like that this is a little bit
more
showy and you may have seen this in a
few videos this is a suede jacket
and it's you know it's a tan color it
feels very nice and she said you try it
on put it on the guy of course is you
know trying to
sell it and i really i really liked it
um and i wore this
a lot too you got to be a little bit
careful with it of course if it's going
to rain or
snow because it is suede but this is
quite a nice
gift to have on on on her part so i had
those two things and you know they
wrapped them
up and you know had them in hanging in
the suit thing and all that
and i ended up taking them down to
to carbondale with me in my dad's old
leather whatever you whatever you call
that thing that you put you know suits
and sports coats and stuff like that
into it's a big bag that you can like
hang
so then after that we went to men's
warehouse and she's like listen we
really need to get you a black suit and
i was like
okay i mean this is a lot but
if you want to do that that's that's
really cool
i can definitely use it so we went to
men's warehouse and
you know we were you know shopping
around and looking and we found a really
nice black suit
and it didn't it didn't fit me
perfectly so you know they do the
measurements and all that and they're
like well
we'll we'll tailor it and um
you know it'll be a while because it's
the christmas season probably about two
weeks before it's ready and i was like
well you know i'll be i'll be back down
in carbondale by then
and my mom was like i can send it to you
not not a big deal and
i also got this tie at that time because
you know
black tie goes with a black suit and you
can't go wrong with that
this is not a long tie which is what i
actually
need but you know i managed to make it
work
and it's been part of my wardrobe for a
very long time
i've worn this to quite a few occasions
and that's where the story gets more
interesting
and in some respects deeper and uh
more what would you call it more
profound
that's just a synonym for deeper but
there's there's something to this
so i go home go and home for me as
carbondale illinois at that time i go
down there and you know
get to teaching and all that the
semester begins
and i kind of forget about the black
suit you know i'm not really thinking
about it because i've got that and i've
also got sweaters and
you know i've got enough so i can get
through my my class that i'm teaching
two or three times a week and
look fairly decent and
[Music]
then something happens i get a call
at my trailer and it's from the u.s
consulate in
costa rica where my mom had been on
vacation
and as soon as they told me that i knew
something something was wrong something
bad had happened
and sure enough she died and she died on
a rafting trip um
that i'll tell you more about maybe in
another video sometime
long story short the river was you know
swollen with with you know waters it was
much more dangerous than it was
originally rated as being
the outfit that she was with they had a
number of safety violations
she and another person out of the six
people died
and another one broke his arm
and you know the red cross had to go in
carry out the corpses through the jungle
on their back
and then you know they they get they
find out stuff from the consulate
of course they had to be cremated there
because you're not going to ship a body
you know from one country to another
embalming isn't all the same there and
so
you know she would come back in an urn
with with her
really screw-up boyfriend who i didn't
like at the time and
haven't thought about for years but he
was kind of a schmuck
and um you know i get the call
and the consulate is like well what do
you want to do
and i was like what do you mean what do
i want to do what what do you do in
these
situations and she and you know the the
consul was like
well uh we can send the ashes back home
somebody's got to take them
and we'll send you a death certificate
and we'll you know get the ball rolling
you're going to have a lot of stuff to
do and i said oh
okay and so my my girlfriend at the time
we drove all the way up from
carbondale to brookfield wisconsin
and you know found the spare key
settled in and you know the the whole
idea was kind of
hitting me and at that time i you know
the only other person who was going to
be
helping out because you know my dad died
years and years and years back so it was
my mom
and then her her you know live-in
boyfriend
pr guy and you know i had a sister
uh who was at that time i think like six
seven months pregnant not really in the
best state of mind
you know grief will do things to people
um
and uh you know the the news had hit me
and now i'm i'm thinking
holy crap what you know what what do i
need to do
i mean i've got to call people and
figure out how to arrange for the
funeral
and there's probably a whole bunch of
financial stuff i've got to look at
i don't even know where her papers are
and so you know i'm going around the
house
um you know finding this and that
it took a long time to like disentangle
all the financial stuff eventually
but here's where it comes back to the
clothing um
you know we knew we had to have a
funeral and
i needed that black suit and when i went
into her
her uh study room you know her den
where she had her desk and file cabinets
and all that it was a bedroom that had
been converted into an office
there it was the black suit from men's
warehouse
tailored to my specifications hanging
there
in the closet she had gone and picked it
up before she went
on her trip down to costa rica
and fortunately she had because i you
know i was like
i was thinking to myself oh crap i'm
gonna i'm gonna need that black
suit for this this funeral how ironic
that
she bought that very suit for me
you know we were kind of joking around
oh it's great for funerals
not knowing it would be used for her
funeral as the first time that i
i wore it and there it was
she had you know without
thinking about this in those ways
provided for
me in a time when i was going to
try to do justice to you know her will
and
um wishes and honor her
memory and also you know fend off her
her jerk boyfriend trying to get like
equity in the house and stuff like that
and manage you know all this this stuff
that has to happen with
conferring with the priest and you know
my family and
and all you know having my my sister
there with her kind of screw up
fiance at the time um
and so you know having that suit there
and
having this tie there along with it
ready
to at least get through one thing it
really uh
it really meant something and i don't
know exactly
what it means but it was uh it was an
interesting turn of
of fate that um all that generosity all
that sort of like looking
out for for you in that
terrible time in the middle of of winter
[Music]
as i was you know sort of transitioning
from
being a college student and grad student
into being
something other than that growing up a
bit that
the suit was there for me i don't have
it anymore
i you know sort of wore it out
and um i think we donated it
at one point to to someone so maybe
somebody else is
getting some good benefit out of it at
this point but
i thought that was you know something
that as i was
picking out my tie for a video that i
did earlier today
i was looking at it and remembering
wearing this tie in the receiving line
at the funeral and when i gave the
eulogy and all those sorts of things and
that she had uh gifted it to me just
uh you know a month and a half if
if even that earlier in
the previous year so that's the the
story about
the tie and these sports jackets and the
black
suit
you